McCABE AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP
QUESTIONED McCABE.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, HE LIED ABOUT
NOT LEAKING.
I'M NOT SNEAKY, I DON'T LEAK.
KELLYANNE CONWAY, COUNSEL FOR
THE PRESIDENT.
THIS HELPS DONALD TRUMP TONIGHT.
THIS IS A BIG, BIG BEGINNING TO
THE END OF WHAT HAS BEEN A WITCH
HUNT FOR THEM DAY ONE.
>> SEAN, THIS WEEK, WE HAVE THE
COMEY BOOK AND OUT TONIGHT WE
FINALLY HAVE A COMEY BLOCKBUSTER
THAT WOULD INTEREST AND ANIMATE
THE PUBLIC.
WHAT YOU JUST REVEALED IS TRULY
REMARKABLE AND BREATHTAKING ON
MANY DIFFERENT LEVELS.
HE REVEALED WHAT THE PRESIDENT,
WHAT TO COMEY ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT WAS ASKING THEM TO DO,
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY, NOT WHAT
COMEY CLAIMS THAT PRESIDENT WAS
ASKING THEM TO DO.
I THINK THE MOST REMARKABLE
THING ABOUT WHAT YOU JUST
REVEALED IS THAT THIS IS A
PRESIDENT WHO FROM THE BEGINNING
HAS BEEN COMPLIANT AND
TRANSPARENT AND HAS NEVER GOTTEN
AWAY FROM THIS INVESTIGATION.
WHAT'S REMARKABLE TO ME THIS
WEEK, 30 DAYS OF COMEY IS GOING
TO BE ABOUT 29 AND A HALF DAYS
TOO MUCH.
HE'S ALREADY NOT WEARING WHILE
ON THE SO-CALLED BOOK TOUR.
FOR SOMEBODY TO NAME HIS BOOK
"LIES IN LEADERSHIP," IS HE
TALKING ABOUT ANDREW McCABE,
HIS NUMBER TWO, WHO JUST HAD A
CRIMINAL REFERRAL TONIGHT,
ADMITTED LAWYER?
WHAT LEADERSHIP?
THE PEOPLE AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL
WHO ARE INVESTIGATING
HILLARY CLINTON AREN'T EVEN
BOTHERING TO TELL THE FISA COURT
JUDGE THAT HER POLITICAL ENEMIES
HAVE OFFENDED THAT PHONY DOSSIER
TO THE TUNES OF MILLIONS AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
IN THE CASE OF JAMES COMEY, WHY
DIDN'T HE TELL
PRESIDENT-ELECT TRUMP -- WHY DID
HE WRITE IT ON HIS HAND?
YOUR POLITICAL OPPONENTS FUNDED
THE DOSSIER.
DID NOT BOTHER TO TELL HIM THAT.
HE TOLD GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS, I
CAN'T ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
IT WASN'T PART OF MY GOAL.
IT'S PHONY ALL THE WAY.
THE FACT THAT HE LEAKED, I THINK
HE SHOULD GO ON A COMEY MEMO TO
HER.
LET'S GO TO CALL ME COMEY TOUR.
>> Sean: THE SERIOUSNESS OF
WHAT THEY HAVE FOR THIS COUNTRY
THROUGH.
HE SAID I'M NOT SNEAKY, I DON'T
LEAK, B.S.
HE LEAKED.
HE LEAKED FOR THE PURPOSE --
>> HE ADMITTED UNDER OATH.
>> Sean: YOU ADD EVERYTHING
TOGETHER, HILLARY OBSTRUCTED
JUSTICE, THEY PROTECTED HER
ABSOLUTELY BECAUSE SHE COMMITTED
CRIMES, THAT IS A FACT.
IRREFUTABLE AND
INCONTROVERTIBLE.
IT'S BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT SHE
WOULD WIN UP MY SEAN.
WE WOULD NEVER KNOW ANY OF THIS.
THEY THOUGHT SHE WOULD WIN, THEY
THOUGHT HILLARY WOULD WIN.
>> Sean: EXCEPT US.
>> WE WOULD KNOW NONE OF THIS,
WE WOULD KNOW NONE OF THIS IF
HILLARY CLINTON HAD ACTUALLY
WON, WHICH COMEY ADMITTED, HE
WAS INFLUENCED BY THE PHONY
BALONEY NATIONAL POLLS, THE
STATEWIDE POLLS WERE RELEVANT.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, WE WOULD KNOW
NONE OF THIS, WE WOULD NOT KNOW
THAT THE HIGHEST LEVELS
INVESTIGATING HILLARY CLINTON
HAD THE FIX AND FOR HER AND
AGAINST CANDIDA TRUMP.
LET THESE MEMOS OUT THERE,
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN CALLING FOR
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
AND CONTINUED INVESTIGATIONS FOR
OVER A YEAR.
PEOPLE HAVE CALLED INTO QUESTION
JIM COMEY'S CREDIBILITY AND
EVERYTHING, THAT'S FINE, BUT I
AM GRASPING HIS RELEVANCE IN
THIS BOOK AWAY THE RELEVANCE IS
PROBABLY IN THESE WAS, NOT IN
THE BOOK.
THIS IS SOMEBODY WHO HARDLY KNEW
THE PRESIDENT, LIMITED AMOUNT OF